Jayda first of all how you doing I'm
good how are you doing I'm good you know
homeschooling is a monster but I'm
hanging it up I'm so glad to be out of
that world I went through all again
homeschooling before but yeah kids are
grown now so I'm glad to be a bow down
to you about that real I'm like anybody
can make it through that is Queen I want
to ask you because during this time one
of the crazy things that's happening is
that people are having these virtual
happy hours people are drinking
themselves to sleep instead of one think
there's four drinks people are really
like you know let's get through this
with a little wine that turns into a lot
wine
but isn't it scary that this can lead to
addiction or it's really troublesome for
people who were dealing with addiction
before well yeah I think that's one of
the reasons why we decided as a family
that we wanted to do a read table talk
around addiction considering you know
our history and unfortunately we've as a
family you know come across some
unfortunate news of some young people
who have a deed you know it's it's it's
been a really trying time for people who
are trying to stay clean or either you
know were in the process of getting
clean I was up a couple of friends who
have problems with you know overeating
and you know so this was a subject that
was in our house a lot so you know we
decided that it would be something just
for us as a family we felt like it was
something important to tackle I want to
ask you about that because overeating is
a real situation for folks right now man
it's like the comfort food that we need
yes how when you all start to talk about
that what did you discover what was the
eating helping you get your do I mean I
think for me
personally and from what I'm seeing
around the household you just get bored
you know what I mean and the kitchen in
in our house is like the heartbeat of
the house you know so which I'm sure it
is for a lot of families I mean that's
where we all convene and you know the
great thing is that we're we're all
eating together for all meals because
there's nothing else to do right but you
just end up hanging out at the kitchen
so all day is like mealtime and so but
the the doctor that we brought on really
gave us really dope tips to help us with
more mindful eating everyone and
everything seems like it's double eating
drew everything and as that happens how
are we gonna pull it back together when
and if this thing ends how are people
gonna pull it back together and would
advice what are you doing to make sure
that you don't fall into that yeah I
mean III talked a little bit about on
the show how even for me I'm you know I
haven't had a drink in a long time but
how those old psychological patterns
that you know once would make me drink
or make me look for solace outside of
myself you know are creeping back in and
because these times are so uncertain you
know you're dealing I'm dealing with you
know old fear patterns you know which
I'm sure a lot of people are dealing
with right now and so you know it's
really for me I've just had to deepen
some of my spiritual practices and even
my faith and I think after this you know
there's just going to be a lot of
recalibrating you know and you know
that's just part of that change is never
easy and you know we just have to all of
those concepts and ideas that got us to
a place of sobriety are the places that
we need to return to and hold on to even
more fiercely than we have
before and we talked about that on the
show different ways in which how to do
that and what it looks like also in this
episode your mother revealed some pretty
shocking things that surprised you and
Willa yeah we were we were having a
conversation that morning and you know
she just talked about the many times
that she had overdosed it actually came
up because unfortunately we had heard
from a family friend of ours about a
young person that we knew who had od'd
and so you know my mother was just
revealing the many times that she had
overdosed which I didn't know I didn't
have knowledge of that but I mean the
great thing about gam and one of the
reasons why I wanted to have this
episode is because you know she's in her
30th year of sobriety and she has so
much information you know to offer to
those who are struggling right now
because of course she wasn't trying to
get clean during a pandemic but you know
she just has some really veteran useful
tips in regards to how to stay clean how
to stay connected and what to do but you
know that's what I love about gam it's
like I always tell people you know you'd
never judge the journey youth you've
been on because once you get through on
the other side you're gonna have so much
to offer other people who are going
through it that as as you once had and
so you know in this episode I was so
proud again because you know one part in
her life she she just didn't want to
talk about this particular journey and I
always told her I was like you know this
is so helpful to to people you know to
talk about what you've been doing how
you've gotten on the other side how was
it as a daughter and then looking at
your daughter digesting that information
well you know I think willows got into
this she's gotten to the point
you know she kind of takes things in
stride machine here some mother and her
grandmother talk because he just
realizes that we we are what you call
well-written upon women and so she's
very clear about that now and I think
she actually really enjoys hearing those
stories and hearing what we've been
through because it's easier for her
because she's gone she gets to see who
we are on the other side you know what
I'm saying
on the up side of the journey so but
what I love about it is that willow just
sits back and just listens and absorbs
and I just think as generations of women
that's that's one of the gifts as elders
that we have to offer you know the the
the younger generation and as well as
the younger generation has to offer us
so you see and you know brillo has some
reveals of her own during the episode I
won't get into that yeah she she
actually came through with some some
very enlightening information as well
yeah did it scare you as a mother oh no
it's a journey that I knew about I was
just glad that she's willing to share it
Jayda throughout the site you guys will
continue shooting throughout the summer
and throughout this whole thing and you
just did the culprit special which I
thought helped so many people what was
the response you got from that special
and especially the people you had on
that talked to us and this is the first
place we really got rock-solid
information
tell me about putting that together you
know I so I have I had a phone call
every month with what I call the red
tape we'll talk oh geez right and
they're a group of people that have been
down from for red tape we'll talk since
day one right and they had their own
groups and so I asked them I said hey do
you think we should do a show on Kovach
19 and they were like please so then I
went and I talked to will and I was like
man I'm really trying to figure out how
can I do this episode so we'll just
started talking and breaking things down
and I was like man you are really laying
this out in a way that that just for the
layman you know what I'm saying just in
a way of which we could understand and
he said well you know I would love to
with this episode so you know will came
on and and we got you know a specialist
and we had a guest to it to talk about
her particular a young person who
actually you know reveal symptoms of
like no taste no smell that I hadn't
even heard of before she came on and so
he came and just kind of helped I really
have to give world props because he came
and really helped to talk about what was
happening in a way that we could all
understand and so a lot that I heard was
hey you know I'm I'm less scared I had
more understanding of why we're being
asked to have social distancing and
what-have-you
because I think people didn't really
understand my social distancing was so
important and it was really about not
collapsing systems our medical system
you know trying to and and just in
general right and also that this
particular virus is so contagious and it
just very quickly right and so to
contain it we had to have social
distancing well not even to contain it
but to stop the spread of it as quickly
as it's spreading so I did hear a lot of
people just talking about how much
comfort they got out of having more
understanding that the specialists that
we had and and we'll coming on really
helped with that and I have to give him
props because he really gave me
direction and how to move forward with
that show and you know just from the
read Table Talk family a lot of people
were asking if we would please do a show
around it
yeah I thought you guys did a fantastic
job I thought dr. will was good yeah dr.
will and I thought and I thought well it
was great everybody was great and I also
thought was funny that will set his
movie I am Legend gave out a bunch of
misinformation he said that's all people
can think about right now they're
thinking that you know
is gonna turn into a legend and he was
like this is not this is not that so you
know he was like let's just figure out
how we can communicate what it actually
is so it was great
Jaden what is the R as you get everybody
together for the read table how hard is
it during these times to get these
things together and you do it it seems
like your team is really really good at
pulling everything together like we're
doing zoom interview right now right did
you do the read table because people
love to come in and sit at the table we
won't be doing that for a while you know
it's a little different but you know
we're doing the best we can we're just
trying to we only shoot when we feel
like it's something that's something
that's needed you know and this
particular show that we did on addiction
we just felt like was the show that was
was needed and it was you know shot with
us who are already in the house so and
we just zoomed folks in but you know we
just we shoot when when we can you know
of course I'm sure you guys understand
also how the process is a lot more it's
it's it's much more it's not as quick as
it used to be you know cuz everybody's
working from home so you know edits and
all of that kind of stuff it all just
takes more time
this really has turned into a 24/7 365
day enterprise for you and now it's like
people come with an expectation of these
cut life-changing conversations does it
ever get a little heavy on you cuz every
week people are like cool read.table
they're gonna bring it they're gonna
bring it they're gonna bring it together
bring you know I don't you know I look
at it as as a blessing honestly to be
able to just share some of the journeys
that that we've been through because at
the end of the day you know it's all
about fine
the tools and the information necessary
to give you this thing called life and I
just realized that for me was the most
helpful is when people are willing to
share their testimonies you know that's
where I found the gems to help me on
certain aspects of my journey and so I
just feel really blessed that we have
the opportunity to do it and I feel
blessed that I have family members that
are willing to share their experiences
because you know we've been through a
lot over here you know in in different
ways you know and and so I just feel
really blessed to be able to do that and
you know if people find help or find
comfort in that I'm I love to be in
service in that way this is this is a
lane for me that's easy because it's
something that we just do you know what
I mean but I do look at it as like as
being a service honestly I feel like
when you have certain information to
offer you you should give it you know
and all we have is our journeys it's not
like we have answers but it's like you
say y'all have been on a lot of journeys
so Katie thanks as always you know good
luck with Quarantine life everybody's
okay everybody's got a smile on their
face though we just we just we just on
this wave on a flow you know
[Music]